et si vous n'étiez pas né
et si je n'étais pas né on est passé à
deux doigts de cette possibilité ma mère
aurait dû mourir d'une tuberculose mal
soignée peut-on après en novembre 1965
elle est enceinte de moi à mon premier
mois le petit canton du Jura en Suisse
palpite et bouillonne elle milite pour
un Jura libre elle se retrouve seul face
à des grenadiers elle lance en rigolant
vous n'allez pas charger une femme
enceinte les grenadiers n'ont pas
d'humour les gaz fusent
et les larmes coulent sans moi c'était
ma question
biologique existentielle
c'est aussi la question de ce soir et
sans moi ce qui m'intéresse se situe en
amont comment y répondre collectivement
comment délibérer démocratiquement nous
verrons ensuite comment cette question
est sans moi
reconfigure la manière même d'y répondre
ensemble
elle porte sur une possibilité d'absence
radicale mon absence votre absence elle
porte sur le moi mais comment délibérer
avec des mois multiples
multiplicité des voix Vox et des voix
verries
la cohabitation des vies
comment faire pour que cette question
est sans moi et sans vous et sans les
générations futures est encore un sens
quand la vie humaine ne tient qu'à
quelques degrés avec la fièvre
climatique
pas de transition écologique sans
transition des mois
quand une question est difficile à
trancher souvent on se tourne vers le
vote
or le vote dépend des questions et des
réponses prenons comme exemple la
formulation
et sans moi
première option de question cette
formulation
dépend-elle des habitudes d'une
génération pressée qui a la fin du monde
assez trousse option de réponse oui non
abstention deuxième configuration avec
deux options de réponse cette
formulation dépend-elle d'une génération
pressée ou au contraire
est-elle la quintessence de son génie
troisième configuration selon vous cette
question
a-t-elle petit a aucun sens petit B un
sens petit C2 sens et petit d plus de
deux sens
quatre options
en dehors du vote
j'ai déjà repéré trois façons
et sans moi quel honte de reproche
et sans moi comment allez-vous faire
la menace
vous aurez remarqué que c'est le temps
qui permet d'interpréter le sens
soit dit en passant
ensuite le pays des virtuoses de la
votation chaque citoyen suisse reçoit un
livret comme celui-ci un petit livret
rouge qui présente les arguments des
proposants et des opposants il est
parfois volumineux ici 79 pages et vous
avez quatre objets dont deux objets sur
la réforme des retraites avec du droit
pur c'est le prix à payer pour la
démocratie semi direct
vous comprenez déjà le malaise
il faudrait premièrement que vous
puissiez expliquer aux autres pourquoi
vous avez voté de tel ou telle façon
deuxièmement que vous puissiez vous
exposer à leurs questions et
troisièmement que vous puissiez revoter
sans doute différemment en tout cas en
ayant pris en considération
leur justification
philosophe je suis embarqué depuis plus
de 25 ans dans l'analyse d'expérience
des libératives avec les premières
conférences de citoyens sur les OGM qui
m'a amené à la rédaction d'un ouvrage la
démocratie génétiquement modifiée et
plus récemment le grand débat national
la convention citoyenne sur le climat ou
encore la conférence pour le futur de
l'Europe
mais peut-on seulement
se prononcer sur pareil question par le
vote
commençons avec le moi
l'une des plus vieilles questions de la
philosophie est connais-toi toi-même en
grec gnotis Couton
elle figure sur le temple d'Apollon
Adelphes
même si on n'est pas sûr de son origine
Socrate la reprend il me semble
tout à fait ridicule que l'ignorant
moi-même je cherche à comprendre des
choses qui me sont étrangères je veux
savoir si je suis un monstre plus
compliqué et plus aveugle que typhon ou
si je suis un être plus doux et plus
simple
doté par la nature
d'une part de lumière et de divinité
une première façon de se mettre en
question vous aurez remarqué qu'il met
le compliqué du côté du mal et le simple
du côté du bien
c'est encore trop peu pluraliste à mon
goût
le mois est solidaire de son éthique
c'est magnifiquement mis en scène par ce
grand Shakespeare dans Hamlet
to be on notube
être ou ne pas être telle est la
question
il ne s'agit pas simplement d'être là ou
pas de savoir qui je suis mais qui je
serai
entre détermination et liberté
est responsable
il faut délivrer le moi le délibéré pour
qu'il reste tendu vers cette horizon
du bien et de la vérité nous ne sommes
pas condamnés à la poste vérité la
vérité n'est pas derrière nous la vérité
est devant nous c'est une exigence qui
nous rend libre
et sans moi cette question problématique
quelque chose qui pourrait paraître un
peu à paradoxe
pas de politique pas de transition
écologique sans chaque citoyen
et pourtant si chacun reste séparé
crispé sur ce qu'il croit être son
identité et ses intérêts rien ne peut
changer
pour déjouer le paradoxe il faut passer
de la position d'individus de
consommateurs
d'usagers voire même de citoyens légal à
celle de citoyens responsables il faut
prendre le risque de répondre d'eux
d'être responsable de s'ajuster au
risque de la démocratie délibérative
avec les autres
alors il est vrai le concert délibératif
est parfois dissonant parce qu'il mêle
les perspectives les plus différentes
comme ici dans ce tableau de Viera Da
Silva énigme
la délibération combine les points de
fuite et les points de vue la
délibération
emmène dans un double mouvement une
délibération intérieure avec soi-même et
la délibération politique avec les
autres et vice versa
le mois n'est pas qu'une répétition du
même un idem il est aussi un mois
authentique un propre
ipset idem et XL et deux termes
qu'utilisent le latin pour traduire même
et sur lesquels le philosophe Paul
Ricard a beaucoup joué dans sa petite
éthique soi-même comme un autre il y a
de l'autre en soi mais il faut
s'aventurer bien au-delà avec la
complication
démocratique il faut s'affronter aux
vrais autres au tout autre aux haltères
dira encore le latin il faut ouvrir le
périmètre de ce concert délibératif à
tous les mois possibles et pas
simplement les humains mais les
non-humains hors de la Horde des sapiens
sapiens les animaux autrement vivant
autrement sapiens les plantes et leur
langage qui trouveraient d'ailleurs
ridicule de devoir répondre à la
question et sans moi
il n'y a pas que la question connaît toi
toi-même mais connais le monde voyage
pour pouvoir visiter l'autre côté de
toi-même c'est ce que j'ai fait à l'âge
de 20 ans je suis allé vivre pendant
deux ans à l'île Maurice et en Inde pour
y découvrir le dialogue interligieux
j'ai attrapé un virus celui des formes
extrêmes de pluralisme celui de la
guerre des dieux
l'image dont tue Max Weber pour parler
des conflits de valeurs
d'ailleurs à ce sujet
que répondre à Dieu à la question et
sans moi
quand certains ont décrété sa mort
que d'autres
cacophonisent en parlant à sa place et
que d'autres encore
méditent et scrute son silence
le slogan des TEDx est diffusé des idées
qui valent la peine il ajoute même des
idées qui changent le monde mais
de quel monde voulons-nous quand ils
sont en compétition
qu'espérer quand certains redoutent ce
que d'autres promettent
il faut
s'aventurer au-delà de l'ibnitz et de
son meilleur des mondes possible j'ai
intitulé Un ouvrage la délibération des
meilleurs démons entre précautions et
pluralisme
mal nommer les choses c'est ajouter au
malheur de ce monde cette affirmation de
Brice parrain rendu célèbre par Camus
établit en lien entre la nomination des
choses et le malheur ou le bonheur du
monde mais il ne s'agit pas que de mots
il s'agit de la composition des mots de
l'ordre du discours
l'ordre du discours conditionne les
mondes à venir absents par définition et
abstrait que font et décomposent les
politiques
le désordre du discours
participent au chaos du monde et à la
confusion de son futur
cette petite anecdote d'un garant des
bas public sceptique
le l'illustre bien je ne sais pas
comment résumer les choses entre ceux
qui sont d'accord avec ceux qui ne sont
pas d'accord et ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord avec ceux qui sont d'accord
narration
interprétation
argumentation sont des pièces
essentielles de l'ordre du discours ils
permettent
de se coordonner et de prendre des
risques avec la conversation il
permettent d'exprimer les désaccords et
les incertitudes avec la délibération
avec la considération ils prennent soin
en même temps des participants à la
discussion et de toutes les dimensions à
prendre et à soumettre à un examen
attentif pour arriver collectivement non
pas un jugement expéditif mais un
jugement tout bien considérait
niet lumineux sur ce point qui estime
la rhétorique est un art essentiellement
républicain il faut être capable de
supporter les opinions et les points de
vue les plus contraires et les plus
étrangers et en même temps éprouver un
certain plaisir à la contradiction il
faut écouter aussi bon gré que l'on
parle soi-même et comme l'auditeur il
faut pouvoir apprécier à peu près l'art
mise en œuvre
j'ajouterai
la rhétorique du silence
celle qui est à l'œuvre dans vos
cerveaux à l'instant
tout ça
m'amène à cette question qui est
finalement une question philosophique
connaît les autres pour pouvoir savoir
comment faire connaître qui tu es ce que
tu veux et ce que tu désires
c'est cette question qui m'a donné
rendez-vous avec vous ce soir sans elle
j'aurais pu louper me louper
peut-être bien
la délibération avec les autres n'est
pas abstraite du tout elle est charnelle
elle est émotionnelle on la pratique
depuis la nuit des temps pour cela ils
font non pas entrer dans un temple mais
entrer dans un théâtre le théâtre et le
lieu par excellence de l'Incarnation et
de l'expérience d'autres que soi le
théâtre c'est l'auditoire vous or
l'argumentation qui est une pièce
essentielle de la délibération dépend de
l'auditoire d'un auditoire universel
mais comment fabrique-t-on un auditoire
universel un auditoire de multiples
c'est tout le problème du système
délibératif qui permet de faire tenir
ensemble les scènes les délibérations
situées les mini publics le Parlement
une assemblée de citoyens et le système
institutionnel un théâtre de théâtre
bon il est vrai que la pièce et les
acteurs ne sont pas toujours bon
c'est vers le taâtre que les philosophes
de l'antiquité se sont tournés pour
inventer un concept essentiel pour le
moi qui lui donne son épaisseur et qu'il
le met en relation avec le monde la
personne la personne désigne le visage
la face de l'acteur réel en grec et en
latin le masque
l'acteur joue par sa personne son
personnage pour le rendre crédible en
face à face avec le public qui lui au
même prend son jeu dans cette jeu de
croyance
le théâtre et le masque ont commencé
avec la religion la politique le théâtre
c'est même
associé aux dieux ici le Dieu par
excellence Dionysos dieu du théâtre avec
ses modes d'existence la comédie et la
tragédie Bacchus chez les Latins Dieu de
l'excès dieu de la critique du monde
dieu de la vendange et du vin tiens mon
nom le palindrome Reber qui signifie en
allemand le vigneron la personne nous a
été donnée aussi par le théâtre pour
penser des choses dont on a discuté ce
soir les personnes grammaticales je il
tuait les autres qui sont associés aux
positions que qu'occupent des personnes
dans un dans une conversation les
personnes du droit personne morale
personne physique personne juridique qui
nous permettent d'imputer des
responsabilités et en théologie les
personnes qui essaient de scruter des
mystères comme l'incarnation ou la
Trinité Père Fils esprit il y a même en
philosophie un courant de pensée le
personnalisme une personne c'est un moi
qui s'éprouve immédiatement communité
alors qu'il compose avec une diversité
de moments vécus disséminés dans le
temps
la personne aussi entre deux pôles
extrêmes la personne comme irremplaçable
la personne comme absence on aurait pu
intitulé Le TEDx de ce soir de façon
encore plus provocatrice et percutante
personne
[Applaudissements]